March is almost over so where is this
Apple event that we were all expecting
hello and welcome back to Apple Park
we're so excited to introduce an all-new
MacBook Air around M2
apple has a ton of different products in
the works and we just passed the last
days that they could have announced a
March event so when are we going to be
getting these products and when can the
next event be well today we're going to
talk about that when I think it is
coming and why along with the different
products that I'm excited about and you
guys are as well now nearly every spring
in March Apple has an event last year
they released the M1 Ultra Mac Studio
they have the new M1 iPad Air which we
were not expecting and in previous years
we had things like the Apple TV 4K iPad
Pros Apple watches and more more but
this year since March is almost over
some people are saying that we might
have to wait for WWDC which is all the
way in June but personally I don't agree
and the first reason why is that WWDC is
a software developers conference that
isn't focused on Hardware now yes last
year WWDC we did get the M2 power
13-inch MacBook Pro and 13-inch M2
MacBook Air and that was excellent but
if we take a journey back the year
before Apple talked about iOS 15 iPad OS
Mac OS watch OS we didn't get any
hardware at all and you have to go all
the way back to 2019 for the previous
time we had Hardware with the math Pro
and with those products we had to wait
another half a year before they actually
ship the year before that in 2018 we had
no no Hardware now this year at wwc most
people are expecting Apple's new virtual
reality headset and that makes complete
sense because you need a ton of software
to make this work but what about all of
these other products now looking back at
the previous announcements when we did
have Hardware Apple kept it very limited
at the software event so personally I
think it'd be very weird for Apple to
release these upcoming products at wwc
and then have enough time for the
headset and all the software that they
usually show off so with that said when
will we get an event personally I think
it's gonna be next month in April just
about two years ago we had an April
event in 2021. it was a really big deal
for Apple being at their campus there
the spring-loaded event and they
announced a bunch of stuff so with all
the leaks and rumors of upcoming Apple
products I think it makes absolute sense
to have an April spring event and let's
go ahead and talk about what we have
coming up now the first product that we
are expecting and I'm absolutely hyped
for is the 15 inch MacBook Air even
though we have so many different
MacBooks here and I can use anyone that
I have that we need for this YouTube
channel oftentimes I would grab the
empty MacBook Air over a 14 inch or a 16
inch just because how nice it is to use
but my only issue with it is that
sometimes if you really want to dig in
that screen is just too small so a 15
inch MacBook Air that is super thin not
much heavier than the 13 inch and coming
in at a price tag let's say it's 1500
bucks that is Affordable would be
amazing and that's exactly exactly what
we have with our leaks Apple just
recently filed new listings for products
using Bluetooth 5.3 in the Bluetooth
launch Studio database which typically
happens shortly before new Macs are
released now we have rumors of this
15-inch MacBook Air along with of course
the Mac Pro which we'll talk about and
Ming shikwo gave us some info stating
that these could be released in Q2 or
later now q1 is January February and
March and Q2 starts in April May and
June now personally I was expecting this
to come with the M2 Chip just like the
13-inch MacBook Air and that would be
perfectly fine but what is interesting
is that minchiko said that this could
also come with the M2 Pro chip and a
more powerful charger which would be
absolutely amazing now in the past Apple
has never had for a very long time
enough for the edible large size display
they always made you pay way more even
with the 15 inch MacBook Pro to get the
larger screen and I think this could
make sense because that'd be a way to
have a model that's affordable but then
that would also give them the
opportunity to let people spend the
extra money to upgrade to the M2 Pro
just like in the Mac Mini now what's
also interesting is that Ming shiko is
saying that it might not be called the
MacBook Air the air is always super thin
super light we've never had a 15 inch
version and I think that could also make
sense to have this just be called the
Macbook so it's right there in the
middle as far as price point and size
while still being thin and light and
giving people a reason to upgrade to the
higher end ones now along with that we
have the Mac Pro that we have been
waiting for for years now and we know it
has to because of Apple's two-year
transition that they previously stated
now before we also expecting a quad chip
design and extreme chip but now looks
like we could be getting the M2 Ultra
instead and even though unfortunately it
doesn't look like we're gonna have
upgradeable RAM on the positive end it
looks like we are gonna have swappable
brains where you can actually take out
the main unit out of the chassis the
power supply all that just stays in the
case and upgrade down the line for less
money and stay more current while
getting all the benefits of the unified
memory design now with that that also
could mean that we will not be getting a
new Mac Studio I know some people have
been writing me asking about that but
because it'll be so similar to the Mac
Pro that also just has an M2 Ultra it
really wouldn't make sense so even
though I would love a new Mac Studio
with an M2 Max chip at a lower price
point most likely that will not happen
that will not be coming out at this
event now we also had leaks of an iPad
Pro but being that that just got updated
with a very minor update that will most
likely not be coming out and the
infamous M3 chip with the 13-inch M3
MacBook Air that is also gonna be pushed
back further now the real question is
will the 15-inch MacBook Air come out
with the M2 Chip and then not much after
maybe half a year or so we could get a
13 inch with M3 and the leaked upcoming
new iMac that can also have the M3 chip
will that make sense to split up those
machines and have a 15 inch that is
behind now personally I think it would
help Apple having a device release
earlier that is going to be a very very
popular device bringing in revenue and
then updating that one later I think
that would make more sense but there is
still a chance they could wait for both
of these now of course we have the
headset and with that like I mentioned I
think that makes way more sense coming
out in June at WWDC so we should not be
expecting that so you guys let me know
what do you think about this what are
the chances of an April event instead of
waiting till June or even later and are
you excited about the upcoming Mac Pro
or this 15-inch MacBook or MacBook Air
whatever they decide to call it Go and
click that Circle above to subscribe
check out one of those videos right over
there that's been Max and I'll see you
in the next one
[Music]